[Music]
[Applause]
Our food, our health, our animals, our
environment, all connected in one
system. And at the root of it,
plants. They give us the oxygen we
breathe, the food we eat, the feed our
animals need.
But plant health is under threat from
plant pests, diseases, and climate
change. When plants are in crisis, the
web of life begins to unravel. A single
pest outbreak can destroy harvests and
fuel hunger, spread harmful
pathogens, increase the risk of
zooonautic diseases, and antimicrobial
resistance affecting every one of us.
But we can protect our plants through
science, innovation, and global
cooperation to make sure plant health is
at the heart of one health. FAO and the
International Plant Protection
Convention, IPCC, are leading the way.
Establishing global standards, advancing
plant health policies, building
capacities, investing in early warning
systems to put one health into
action. Join us in the global effort to
protect plants in our future. When we
protect plants, we protect one health,
we protect life.
[Music]